bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7,8 week-end comme tous
les vendredis nous allons revenir
pendant 26 minutes sur les moments forts
de l'actualité culture loisirs et sports
au cours de cette émission nous
parlerons télé réalité le concept qu'est
ce qu'on mange ce soir arrive dans les
yvelines et sera diffusé sur notre
antenne au printemps sachez le nous en
parlerons avec la directrice du centre
national d'édition dar es images sylvie
boulanger tout à l'heure mais tout
d'abord ce mercredi évidemment c'était
le premier jour des soldes nous nous
sommes rendus à l'ouverture d'un
supermarché de maurepas
les clients ont bien entendu répondu
présent comme tous les ans mais
l'enseigne s'attend à une baisse de la
fréquentation cette année
reportage signé claire cambier elodie
moines
dans ce supermarché les salariés ont
passé une partie de la nuit à étiqueter
à placer les produits à quelques minutes
de l'ouverture on finalise les
rayonnages tout doit être prêt pour
l'arrivée des clients 8h30 le rideau se
lève derrière une centaine de personnes
bien décidées à profiter des soldes
premier arrivé premier servi le mieux à
faire ses premiers jours c'est parmi les
premières armes
le magasin propose des réductions allant
jusqu'à -70% de quoi faire des affaires
et là à chacun sa technique il y a ceux
qui fouillent et ceux qui ont bien
préparé leur tâche j'ai fait mon opéra
j'espère que j'ai trouvé mon bonheur
dans tous les cas les caddies se
remplissent vite même si cette année
l'enseigne prévoit une baisse de la
fréquentation
c'est vrai que le
l'élasticité moins importante quand même
que ce qu'on pouvait connaître il ya
quelques années parce que ben oui a
beaucoup beaucoup de promotions et
d'opérations tout au long de l'année
danse avec sadie lune quand même un
petit peu un petit peu l'impact des
soldes malgré tout il reste quand même
un delta qui n'ont avec déjà les
magasins de vêtements plus
particulièrement ont lancé des ventes
privées des soldes avant les soldes
c'est tout de même dans le textile que
ce supermarché compte faire son plus
gros chiffre d'affaires en règle
générale les ventes du rayon vêtements
atteignent 100 mille euros le premier
jour et en cinq semaines de soldes de 10
à 12% du chiffre d'affaires annuel
malgré la baisse du pouvoir d'achat 62%
des français devraient dépenser plus de
100 euros pour les soldes une donnée
confirmée par les clients de ce magasin
si j'arrive à tout trouvé aux alentours
de 500 600 euros
il reste jusqu'au 11 février pour
profiter des soldes dans ce magasin si
les collections passées ne sont pas
écoulés d'ici là une partie du stock
sera donné à des associations
comme tous les ans les traditionnelles
illuminations de noël honte éclairer vos
rues un mois après leur installation les
services techniques des communes
saint-quentinoise les retire pour
laisser place à l'hiver
retour sur la magie de ses lumières
reportages réalisés avec patrick jacques
de dixmude elodie mois
à la nuit tombée elles ont éclairé votre
chemin pour laisser l'esprit de noël
flotter dans vos rues
clignote scintille doré verte ou bleue
leurs couleurs féeriques réchauffe les
coeurs et vous souhaite une bonne année
chaque carte hier sa décoration chaque
rue son étoile de noël mais c'est
souvent le centre-ville le plus
étincelant comme à magny les hameaux où
les anciennes lampes à incandescence ont
peu à peu laissé la place aux led plus
légère plus robuste et surtout plus
économes
les années précédentes dont tournés au
fil lumière donc qui tournait à 14 watts
au met et l'a donc cette année on tourne
à quatre atomes est donc il ya quand
même une une consommation moins
importante à manier un mot plus de 170
illuminations scintiller mais un mois
après leur installation les guirlandes
doivent repartir à l'atelier pour
laisser place aux douceur de l'hiver et
il faudra désormais attendre un an pour
que la magie de noël s'empare à nouveau
de vaulruz
ce lundi 6 janvier j'imagine que
beaucoup d'entre vous ont dû fêter
l'épiphanie
l'occasion évidemment de savourer la
traditionnelle galette des rois une
galette que certains pâtissiers vinoy
souhaite encore fabriquée de manière
artisanale
olivier maniscalco et patrick jacq
d'énigmes se dit sûre ans et de l'eau et
du sucre qu'on a fait bouillir tout
simplement voilà c'est ce qui les fait
briller toujours chaud à la sortie du
foie
elle célèbre la visite des rois mages
auprès de l'enfant jésus elle s'est bien
sûr la galette de l'épiphanie à
chevreuse dans la boulangerie pâtisserie
d'hervé bové ont la cuisine de manière
traditionnelle du beurre frais de la
poudre d'amandes 100% pur fruit du sucre
de la farine et de la crème pâtissière
pour la frangipane ici la méthode est
artisanale
tout est fait à la main alors il n'y a
qu'une seule machine pas même deux à une
machine qu'est d'affaires la crème c'est
le batteur mélangeur et une autre
machine s'appelle le laminoir pour
étaler la pâte
parce que quand il ya beaucoup de pâtes
voilà ce sont le seul machine tout est
fait à la main une méthode
traditionnelle qui élèvent forcément le
tarif à la caisse alors qu'elle coûte 2
4 à 10 euros en grande surface légal est
aussi rond plus entre 10 et 20 euros
chez un artisan pâtissier
pourtant les clients restent fidèles au
rendez vous ici c'est la de pâtisserie
est très bonne c'est pour ça chez mes
artisans je suis madame beauvais tout
est bon mais quote-part ce principe bon
maintenant pour son argent un aîné qui
sont pas difficiles
près de 20 millions de galettes sont
achetés chaque année en france à
chevreuse de 750 à mille cinq cents
pièces seront vendues en un mois et demi
ce qui représente environ 15% du chiffre
d'affaires d'hervé mauvais presqu'autant
que pour les fêtes de noël
je le disais dans les titres de ce set 8
week-end la télé réalité arrive dans les
yvelines avec l'émission qu'est ce qu'on
mange ce soir concept imaginé par
l'artiste belge jeff games une émission
inédite que vous pourrez d'ailleurs
découvrir au printemps sur notre antenne
et pour en parler sylvie boulanger la
directrice du centre national d'édition
dar et l'image est présente sur ce
plateau bonjour alors tout d'abord
qu'est ce qu'on va manger quel est le
concept a le concept c'est d'imaginer
que le dîner qu'on fait tous les soirs
en fête en famille peut être élevée à la
hauteur d'une oeuvre d'art c'est à dire
un petit peu de rendre ce on va dire ce
moment peut être banal dans certaines
familles un peu plus attrayant c'est ça
leur donne et peut-être des lettres de
noblesse oui lettres de noblesse c'est
peut-être que le mot c'est moins
attrayant que conscience se dire on se
rend pas compte de tous les dîners qu'on
fait quand même dans une vie et de temps
en temps c'est peut-être important de 2
se rendre conscience d'être conscient
qui se passe pas mal de chose qui peut
se passer pas mal de choses dans un
dîner comment est venue cette idée de
deux fermes d'un dîner une télé réalité
de la part de cet artiste belge c'est
oui c'est cet artiste en fait que tu
ailles ce qu'un jeune homme qui à 80 ans
cette année en 2014 et qui a un immense
artiste en fait un très grand artiste
qu'était qu'a représenté la belgique à
labinal de de venise qui à rotterdam qui
est dans des très grandes expositions et
cet artiste n'a en fait n'a jamais fait
la différence entre ce qui pouvait être
une oeuvre d'art noble ou
issue d'une culture savante et puis un
acte intime privé
voilà tel que ce qu'on fait tous les
jours comme par exemple dîner en famille
voilà voilà comment on peut élever
justement ce un dîner à ce stade d'art
comme vous le dit l'expression peut-être
ne peut-être juste en le rendant
justement un peu conscients et sans
essayer de le décorer c'est à dire que
là le principe c'est de une famille est
d'accord pour se faire filmer en famille
lilloise une famille viennoise
absolument nous recrutons
line web et et ont installé une caméra
devant la table de la salle à manger et
voilà et on se retire on s'en va c'est à
dire que la famille se retrouve en fait
son intimité et c'est toute la question
c'est de devenir sensible à cette
intimité et le produit on est entre
guillemets final que l'on va voir être
diffusé sur notre antenne ça va être un
montage derrière où on va laisser le la
séquence filmée avec la caméra pendant
le dîner brut alors justement non il n'y
a pas de montage comme nos commandes
dans la télé réalité classique où il ya
effectivement un projet où il ya souvent
des objectifs on anticipe parfois même
on fait dire il faut bien le dire les
choses voilà qui n'était pas forcément
prévu ou naturels ou voilà ou intuitive
et là il n'y a absolument aucun objectif
aucun marketing il n'y a pas de montage
derrière et c'est ça qui est important
parce qu'il se passe quand même beaucoup
de choses c'est à dire partir du moment
où à la france sait filmer ou à partir
du moment où on se commence à se
demander à oui c'est important quand
même cette intimité en famille cela veut
dire que je vais je vais un peu l'avocat
du diable passe moi le sel par exemple
ça peut être
cette expression le geste pourrait
devenir extrapoler ce serait vous voyez
pas si bien dire parce que je votre
question me fait penser un autre artiste
hans peter feldmann grande artiste
allemand et qui a fait une série
d'oeuvres qui a été exposé aussi dans
les plus grands musées
voilà en france et à l'étranger et il ya
une des oeuvres c'est juste sa
collection de salière c'est à dire le
face à face de plusieurs salles hier
qu'il a utilisé dans ses dîners et qui
deviennent une oeuvre d'art comme quoi
tout tout seul peut être mise en
évidence et par rapport à 7 ce concept
de télé réalité vous avez envie aussi
envie à travers ce cette émission de
redorer peut-être d'un certain côté
l'image de la télé réalité qu'on sait
qui parfois les programmes ne sont pas
tout le temps génialissime alors dans
télé réalité il ya deux mois et la télé
réalité
je pense que le projet de jef geys et
effectivement on va dire de redorer
l'image de la réalité
de la télé je ne suis pas sûr
et vous n'avez pas peur que justement
cela soit un peu noyé dans tout dans
tous ces concepts de télé réalité est-ce
que comment ça pourrait sortir du lot
enfin les ipad il lâché oui on présente
pas la chose comme comme un concept de
télé-réalité mais plutôt vraiment comme
une expression artistique
c'est à dire le film est un dîner se
filmer en train de dîner peut être une
expression artistique donc on ne va pas
jouer dans la même cour les grandes
émissions de télé des superproductions
vous recherchez encore des familles je
crois que c'est une vingtaine de
familles dont vous avez besoin pontage
on leur cherche encore si ce donc
bienvenue ils pourront répondre aux
coordonnées qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran je crois que le premier tournage
c'est pour ce soir ce vendredi du côté
du vésinet évidemment dans les yvelines
et donc on se donne rendez vous au
printemps à peu près pour la première
diffusion sur notre enfance au mois de
mars oui merci beaucoup si vous longez
d'être passé sur le plateau du site you
can et puis à bientôt donc au mois de
mars pour la première émission après
avoir laissé son empreinte sur la face
cachée de la lune thierry balasse 10
sous la frontière entre les mots et les
notes et il veut essayer de plonger la
parole de jean jaurès au coeur de la
musique pour un concert intemporel
prévue ce mardi orillia de bissy et
jonathan big man
la précitée
la cour jeudi
lors de l'accord
le courage selon jean jaurès ce sont ces
paroles extraites du discours à la
jeunesse prononcé en 1903 qui ouvre le
spectacle une création sonore à
l'univers électro acoustique dans lequel
viennent s'insérer des textes de jean
jaurès issus essentiellement de discours
et d'extrait de son mémoire
philosophique c'est la lecture de la
réédition de ses mémoires qui interpelle
thierry balasse il ya quelque chose moi
qui me touche dans la démarche de cet
homme dans sa démarche intellectuelle
et que j'ai découvert en lisant son
mémoire de philosophie l'idée que cet
homme a eu un engagement dans le concret
ce quelqu'un qui s'est beaucoup engagé
aux côtés des ouvriers des paysans et
que tout cet engagement il vient en fait
d'un rapport au monde d'un rapport à la
nature et je trouve ça assez intéressant
sega ne pas subir la loi du mensonge
triomphant
de ne pas faire les cons
ce spectacle propose des moments qui
sont assez pop des moments qui font
qu'ils font référence à de la musique
ancienne on va vers les folies d'espagne
vers debussy une petite citation de
debussy mais malgré tout on est aussi on
a aussi des moments qui sont plutôt dans
la musique expérimentale alors une
musique qui reste très équitable mais
qui reste dans la recherche et jean
jaurès dit quelque chose moi qui m'a
beaucoup touché il dit par exemple un
son nouveau c'est la révélation d'une
force nouvelle d'une parcelle dame
inconnue et je trouve ça intéressant
cette idée que on peut avoir plusieurs
rapports à la musique il ya cette
musique qui répond à des codes sur
lequel on est tous d'accord les rapports
harmonique rythmique sur lesquels on est
tous d'accord qui sont un peu notre
culture commune et ça c'est super
agréable à écouter parce que parce que
c'est évident et une espèce d'évidence
dans les routes et puis dit jean jaurès
y une autre musique plus expérimental
qui est peut-être un tout petit peu plus
compliqué à écouter mais qui peut être
nous met en relation avec des parties de
notre âme que nous ne connaissons pas
encore je trouve que c'est un bel
hommage à l'art contemporain en général
un voyage musical intemporel autour
d'une réflexion sur le mouvement la
lumière et le son
en ce début d'année la commanderie des
templiers de lavilledieu à elancourt a
ouvert ses portes au public l'occasion
pour les curieux de découvrir les faces
cachées de ce haut lieu du patrimoine
saint quentinois violent torres et
patrick jacq de beechwood vont font la
visite
en bus
retour à l'époque des croisades du
moyen-âge nous sommes à la commanderie
des templiers de lavilledieu à elancourt
à l'époque au 12e siècle les religieux
basé à jérusalem se rendent compte que
les routes sont pavées de danger pour
les pèlerins c'est à partir de là que
sont nées les templiers ce sont eux qui
vont défendre les routes menant jusqu'à
la ville sainte et c'est ici dans les
commanderies qu'il se forme à l'art de
la guerre
les templiers sont des chevaliers et on
les envoyer pas combattre en orient tant
qu'il n'était pas formé et ici vous
pouviez être formée à l'art de la guerre
notamment l'art équestre guerre de cent
ans guerre des religions le site connaît
les aléas l'histoire de france les
destructions sont importantes mais les
bâtiments restants demeurent au xiiie
siècle la france comptait près de 1000
commanderie il ne reste que très peu
aujourd'hui et ont souvent une
caractéristique commune la chapelle est
souvent voire exclusivement plus petit
que les autres bâtiments pour rappeler
que les templiers non pas une vocation
uniquement religieuses mais uniquement
une vocation militaire et agricoles
puisque les commanderies fournissez
l'ensemble des ressources pour les
templiers qui partait combattre en
orient aujourd'hui le lieu est ouvert au
public et accueille aussi des
expositions d'art contemporain
patrice et voisins depuis des années
pour la première fois il a visité la
chapelle la restauration le seul os x
intel et j'ai jamais eu l'occasion et
d'aller soit une conférence soit à des
la musique dans la chapelle donc ça me
donne envie la prochaine fois quand tu
auras quelque chose va devenir bien sûr
la prochaine fois ce sera le 2 février
une visite organisée par le musée de la
ville
en sport ce premier week-end de janvier
était consacrée évidemment comme tous
les ans à la coupe de france de football
poissy dernier club yvelinois amateurs
encore en lice recevait les bretons de
concarneau pensionnaire de cfa mais
l'exploit ne s'est pas produit
malheureusement au stade léo lagrange
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
si le match des tribunes et vite gagnés
par les supporters de concarneau c'est
tout l'opposé sur le terrain du stade
léo lagrange après un début de match
très prudents les joueurs de poissy ici
en jaune asphyxie le milieu breton et
ils sont même tout près d'ouvrir le
score sur cette splendide ouverture mais
la reprise de l'attaquant kiciak est
passé tout près de la lucarne bretonne
voici prend alors confiance et les
occasions se multiplient mais à chaque
fois nos cadres il aime pour la cage
adverse évident
0 0 à la pause
le tournant du match arrive peu après la
mi temps le défenseur central abdoulaye
sangaré est expulsé pour ce tacle en
retard
il n'en fallait pas plus aux joueurs de
concarneau pour prendre l'aventage à la
70e minute l'avant-centre aux bretons
soki n'zinga met fin aux espoirs
hesdinois sur cette frappe croisée du
gauche concarneau s'impose finalement
1-0 et verra les seizièmes de finale 24
ans après de leur côté les ivy loi
pourront regretter longtemps leurs
nombreuses occasions ratées on n'avait
pas fait un grand début de match
peut-être impressionné par l'événement
met tout de suite derrière on a on a
comment on s'est bien ressaisi on a bien
joué on allait on a les occases et on
l'aimé pas et
et puis après l'expulsion et le tournant
du match en seconde période l'expulsion
très sévère on jouait pour la qualif on
a perdu donc frites une déception comme
chaque année la compagnie d'arc
d'elancourt organisé son traditionnel
concours qualificatif pour les
championnats de france les prochains
championnats de france en salle mais
aussi ultime étape de sélection pour les
mondiaux à nîmes au printemps prochain
des archers de l'équipe de france et est
évidemment présent sur le pas de tir
sous l'oeil avisé de patrick jacques de
dixmude au milieu des 380 participants
pour la plupart amateurs certains archi
ressemble plus de tension sur la corde
de leur art le vice champion d'europe
2011 sébastien peineau est présent sur
le pas de tir d'elancourt pour se
qualifier pour les prochains
championnats du monde en salle rester
concentrés dans sa bulle voilà faire
attention à tout ce qu'on fait savoir
analyser son son tir pour si jamais une
erreur savoir l'analyse et apporter un
peu plus de sens d'attention dessus par
la suite pour éviter de répéter la même
erreur nouvelle records ou man de france
du tir en salle en arc à poulies sophie
dodémont fait partie logiquement des
favorites pour obtenir son ticket pour
le groupe france où seuls les 8
meilleurs archers seront retenus
l'objectif c'est pas de rentrer dans les
huit l'objectif c'est de ces de faire un
résultat sur le championnat du monde
donc si effectivement j'ai des
difficultés à rentrer dans les huit ça
sert à rien qui aille plus loin donc
voilà j'ai fait le tir il fallait le
faire et tant mieux dimanche matin
sophie dodémont réalise un bon score de
584 points sur 600 possibles avec ce
total elle valide facilement son ticket
pour la sélection nationale qui aura
lieu donc un jour et tire toujours après
une médaille d'or aux mondiaux peut-être
à nîmes fin février
le mma et l'art martial par excellence
de nombreuses disciplines le composent
évidemment le free fight continue de se
développer et arrive à maurepas ou 1000
mètres carrés sont désormais dédiés aux
arts martiaux aux arts martiaux modernes
pardon loin de sa réputation de combats
de rue ce sport est devenu très
technique et très encadrée patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images formé
au sol au grappling basile note doit
encore travailler la qualité de sa box
pour devenir un combattant complet et
pourtant rien ne le prédestinait au free
fight car avant d'entrer dans l'octogone
il pratiquer le badminton cet éducateur
spécialisé a vite adhéré aux valeurs
dans la cage où se côtoient toutes les
catégories sociales on sait les
exigences que ça chacun entre
combattants et forcément elle afin
d'avoir fait un combat voilà on se prend
dans les bras parce que voilà on
respecte l'autre pour tous qui même si
on a gagné qu on est perdu ou que voilà
il ya vraiment un respect mutuel parce
qu'on sait la douleur que ça peut être
pour se préparer
la france est le dernier pays européen
qui interdit les compétitions de mma
depuis les années 90 ce sport à la
réputation sulfureuse a beaucoup évolué
l'époque du combat de rue est révolu le
free fight est désormais codifié encadré
et très technique chaque pratiquant de
mma et multidisciplinaire ça veut dire
qu'ils pratiquent un sport de pieds
poings il fait de la lutte ou du judo a
coté et il fait soit du grappling soit
du ju jitsu brésilien pour développer
ses aptitudes au sol contrairement aux
images de violence régulièrement
diffusés des études américaines ont
prouvé que le mma n'est pas plus
traumatiques que d'autres sports de
combat la boxe anglaise qui jouit lui né
d'une image beaucoup plus positive sur
le long terme laissent beaucoup plus de
séquelles que le mma les mecs sont
capables de se mettre entre 500 et 700
coup de poing dans le visage sur un
combat ça engendre des problèmes de
santé après beaucoup plus important que
ce que nous on connait en mma sur 1000
mètres carrés cette salle de sport
presque unique en france propose
également des cours de fitness et
d'ailleurs au boxing
l'abonnement annuel vous coûtera entre
300 et 500 euros
aller avant de passer à l'agenda du
week-end je vous propose d'aller voir
vos résolutions pour la nouvelle année
ne reporter son talent et vous demandez
tout cela dans les rues de saint quentin
j'espère beaucoup de bonheur beaucoup de
travail j'ai essayé de faire du sport
avant tout on sait ce que nous sommes
nés des femmes et que on est un peu plus
de considération pour les femmes
trouver du travail c'est ce qui manque
le plus heureux peut-être aller habiter
au soleil dans un endroit où il fera
plus chaud plusieurs mois dans l'année
quoi changer de travail et font que je
réussissais mon diplôme de doctorat ça
c'est le plus important à faire en 2014
et même 2013
prendre soin de nous
être heureuse pas beau la vie allez pour
terminer cette édition évidemment place
à votre agenda du week-end tout d'abord
ce samedi 11 janvier du sport en basket
le derby de la 14e journée de nationale
3 à suivre opposera l'entente le
chesnay-versailles attrape coup d'envoi
à 20 heures au gymnase mont boron vous
pourrez vous initier dimanche 12 janvier
à la kizomba et à la bachata de danse
très séductrice provenant respectivement
d'angola et de république dominicaine
rendez vous à l'école infinie danse à
trappes à partir de 13h30 ce dimanche
c'est la fin de ce sept huit week-ends
merci encore une fois de l'avoir suivi
pour ma part je vous retrouverai lundi
dans le 7-8 sport avec le nouvel
entraîneur de l'ès montignac balle
philippe l'étrange d'ici là excellent
week-end sur tv fille